[Música]
ar
las escuelas son una parte esencial de
la sociedad y del bienestar de los niños
y es muy importante que puedan estar en
contacto con sus compañeros
por eso concluimos que el cierre de
escuelas debe ser la última medida si
hay que tomar medidas
nuestra sensación principal es
definitivamente de emoción realmente los
extrañamos estamos acostumbrados a pasar
todo el día todas las semanas con los
niños de hecho muchos de ellos no los
hemos visto desde martín rodríguez
count
[Música]
le pedimos al alcalde que asegure que
cada edificio tenga la protección
personal adecuada todos los recursos
necesarios para mantenernos a nosotros
ya nuestros estudiantes y a nuestras
familias a salvo esta es la primera vez
que hacemos esto estoy asustado
absolutamente estoy asustada por mis
compañeros absolutamente estoy asustado
por la ciudad de nueva york
ya
[Música]
de laboral toda la forma de hacer las
cosas desde la entrada al colegio la
salida que no puedan hacer proyectos
cooperativos que no puedan tocar el
mismo material que no puedan incluso
tener contacto entre ellos yo con los
alumnos de alguna manera la cercanía
todo eso va a cambiar muchísimo
[Música]
con la ayuda de los epidemiólogos creo
que los riesgos en las escuelas se han
reducido al mínimo y son inferiores a
los que tenemos cuando vamos a comercios
o en transporte público todo se reduce a
respetar las medidas y le di algunos
consejos a mi hija de nueve años como
que trate de no acercarse demasiado a
sus amigas que se lave las manos con
regularidad y que no se toque la cara le
he dado dos mascarillas las tiene en su
bolso si elige usarlas y también si se
preocupa puede usarlas
no creo que esta sea la nueva normalidad
porque no creo que de aquí hasta el
final de sus años escolares tengamos que
usar mascarillas creo que durará un
tiempo pero ahora está acostumbrado
estoy muy contenta porque después de
tanto tiempo de aislamiento puedo ver a
mis amiguitos y a la profe y puedo
estudiar
[Música]
estaba un poco nervioso por venir a la
guardería mi mamá me mostró algunas
fotos y pensé que se veía divertida así
que ya no estoy nervioso
[Música]
y en la semana
mi mamá me dijo que no le diera a nadie
mis toallitas húmedas comida o agua y
que no me acercará a nadie para que el
coronavirus no venga
[Música]